more than 850 Local Heroes community and
charity representatives from across the
UK have been invited to the king's
coronation while Alice supporter is at
Westminster Abbey Forest this morning so
a huge number of Local Heroes on the
invite list
yes that's right I mean it's incredible
to think four weeks today we're going to
have world leaders dignitaries diplomats
will be descending on Westminster Abbey
but alongside that there's going to be
850 ordinary people who do extraordinary
things every day we've got 450 people
who will be coming to the service to the
coronation at Westminster Abbey and they
are people who received British Empire
medals for services in the community
particularly during the pandemic so it's
very much a thank you to those men and
women for their service but there's also
going to be around 400 young people who
will be attending the service now they
are going to be at St Margaret's Church
which is a small church next to
Westminster Abbey they will watch the
the procession as Charles King Charles
makes his way through to Westminster
Abbey but there'll also be a private
viewing for those 400 people now in
terms of who they are and which
Charities they've come from around half
of them have been put forward from
Charities chosen and by King Charles and
buy the queen consort and they are
Charities that he's very closely
associated with particularly ones that
we associate with young people so
barnardos and the princess trust and
then the other 200 people are from
Charities that the government has put
forward and their volunteer groups such
as girl guiding UK and they'll be
volunteering on the day and it's a very
strong message really from King Charles
about wanting to have Community groups
Community leaders and young people at
the center of this very important
service